so thank you everyone for being here and
uh yeah welcome also from uh everyone
joining remotely
and uh yeah today we're gonna talk about
uh a very practical application of large
language models in particular for public
consultations
and this is work we did with the
planning inspectorate in the United
Kingdom
and who's behind this work well it's me
Michaela de la queza and I freelance on
all things the science and machine
learning and Andreas lead that
unfortunately couldn't be here today but
he's actually joining remotely so hi
Andreas and
a few words about about us so my
background is a computer science in
particular database Management systems
and then switched back to
um data science machine learning and
more recently working more and more with
Anna pre-applications while Andreas his
background is tied in in project in
large project management
yeah construction projects as well so
let's uh let's get into it so what is a
local plan
well a local plan is a is a lot usually
a large document that sets out uh how a
new area is going to be developed in the
last in the next 10 20 years for example
uh it might regulate uh things about
housing or business construction
infrastructure roads facilities uh and
so on and in the United Kingdom Kingdom
it covers a minimum of 15 years so this
is a very large document between 100 and
500 pages that the local Authority
puts together
and that will will regulate how a
certain area will develop in in the next
15 years
and
well once once the draft is ready
everyone can comment on it and
um and all these cons all these comments
get to the council
and and they are called representations
and a single representation uh
might be relevant for one of the
policies uh that is uh defined in the
local plan or potentially more than one
or it it can also apply to to none of
them so the comment itself might not be
really relevant in in terms of uh
soundness or or legality of the policies
and and the world consultation process
really provides an opportunity for
everyone to to object support or comment
uh or suggest revisions of the of the
local plan
and uh
how are representations received well
um by law everyone can comment in in any
way in using any kind of format
so could be a PDF a regular letter and
writing on a napkin uh calling the local
Authority and so literally everything
but uh but yeah recently it's mostly web
forms or PDFs which makes things a bit
easier
now not all representations are equal
some of them are very simple like a
couple lines of text others coming maybe
from from a
a law firm or 50 pages of legal text so
of course complexity in handling the
these different kinds of com of
documents can vary a lot
and how difficult is for the local
authority to process all these documents
well here we we get some some basic
numbers so on average it's a local
consultation uh gets a roughly 7 000
representations so seven thousand
documents arrive and
um yeah and on average uh
to process all of them it takes a 54
person once so it's quite expensive to
process these documents and for most of
the local local authorities
uh it's quite it's quite a challenge and
and for many of them it's actually the
the the most expensive activity in
developing a new local plan so basically
you create a draft and then you you you
open up for public consultations and
digesting and take into account all the
feedback you get it's actually more
expensive than than producing the first
draft so uh it's really uh an intense
process and and here we get the uh uh
bit of details about how much time it
takes to process one single
representation and and what it entails
so so here we see and here we have on
the x-axis percentiles
of the distributions or the y-axis how
many hours it's taken to process one
single representation so it can range
from between five minutes probably it's
a very short simple representation to to
to even 14 hours so probably very large
document uh and and on average each
document takes roughly three hours to
process so again what are the activities
that are involved in processing one
single representation well first of all
you you need to
to read through to understand what it is
about and understand if it applies to to
one policy to more than one policy or
none so each document you have to break
it down understand each paragraph if it
is relevant for for which policy and and
then you search through all the
representations
you create summaries of the
representations around each policy and
this summaries then
addressed and and also shared with
inspectors now here I'm really
simplifying a lot but uh
the the local authorities interact with
the central
planning inspectorate which in turn
assigns inspectors to review the the
proposal and and these inspectors
receive the the summaries of the
representations as a way to to speed up
a bit the the processing on the end
which doesn't make life easier on the
local authorities side
so as you can see there's lots of uh
interactions
and taking into account actually all
these documents
and here we see a bit uh how things what
is the workflow we are trying to to
improve so what is the process so plant
makers go through this process when they
run a new consultation so first of all
the the local planning Authority groups
all the content from the representations
by category which usually it's by policy
uh now we as part of our final
recommendations out of this project we
also recommend it to to Define what a
category is so let's say that uh to
simplify things in in this talk let's
say the category it's a it's a policy
and
what is the challenge here well it's a
rather manual cumbersome task you have
to go through all the text break it down
understand what is the relevant policy
it's quite it's really time consuming
and second step uh the local Authority
gets all this uh
all the text relevant for each policy
creating summaries so for each policy
this is basically a list of topics which
are the challenges and and the local
authorities also commenting on how they
are addressing uh these these issues
and uh right now uh uh there's not
really any dedicated tool to to filter
search through the presentations to to
Really uh select the relevant text for a
certain policy so so how does it work
now giant Excel files uh Postage and uh
uh messing minimal process
and uh yeah and here below we we see the
the process depicted
um now
what uh what we did uh we tried to to to
improve this exactly this process and
how we did it while providing uh
a recommendation on what is the correct
policy uh for each paragraph So
basically predicting what is the
relevant policy for each paragraph We we
tried to to provide a first guess about
the grouping of the paragraphs so that
uh
um for the local planning Authority the
the work left to is really just to to
verify that the categorization is
correct
and and fix errors wherever there are
errors and
and and secondly uh all the all the text
inside representations is now indexed at
the paragraph level so it's not anymore
uh uh a list of uh Black Box documents
uh with some postage around but it's
really indexed text at the paragraph
level you can filter out uh by policy by
topic so it gets much faster also
um to to then create the summaries so
the byproduct of categorization is also
an increased automation integration of
the summaries indirectly the summary
itself is still created manually by the
local Authority but the summary itself
is created is created out of text that
is
filtered out and identified more easily
uh now how is the the the entire
workflow
um working so so first of all the
process starts with uh predictions for
some paragraphs for which uh we for
example identified the the name of the
policy for example uh at the beginning
there's not really any training data to
to to to to to train a model we just
have a bunch of documents a bunch of new
policies that no one saw before so
there's not really any training data and
and the best we can do is to search for
for um for keywords uh and variations of
these keywords uh looking for names of
policies ideas of policies and so on
and uh
yeah in this way we we come up with the
initial predictions uh but for the
majority of the documents we actually
don't have any any prediction yet but we
we now have enough information to to
expose uh the local authorities to to
some of these representations
second iteration
we now have some verified
representations verify the documents
with the correct categories which we can
actually use to train a model so now we
do have some training data and we do
know which are the class labels we have
to predict for and uh and we move
forward in this way so it's an iterative
process where the the the size of the
training data set keeps growing
and also performance of the model keeps
growing and the process is completed
once all the representations
have a verified categorization
and
yeah
yeah up to this point we we only saw
representations but actually
its examination sorry it's a
consultation that actually is about an
examination Library contains more than a
single document so we do have this very
large PDF document
with no standardized format every every
Council in the United Kingdom can can
decide on their own format and structure
of this document they are just some
loose recommendations on how to
structure it
but I would say not enough to to
to process it easily we also have a list
of policy names policy IDs list of
representations
there are also many other documents
legal attachments environmental
evaluations lots of
maps and just special information
which we are currently not using we
really just use the local plan the the
list of the policies and the
representations in this in the scope of
this project
and again here we have some examples of
how representations might look like so
they might be quite long and specific so
you have two opponents from this
opponents it might get easier to
understand what is the policy
if a policy is relevant or not for
example there might be a policy about
new settlements in a certain area now
toponyms as you can imagine are quite
important to derive the classification
process while in other cases there might
be representations where the entire text
is just I like it you don't really have
any correct category for for this
representation so you shouldn't this
also means that from out of your
classification process you shouldn't
expect a super high accuracy neither
and uh
yeah as we say as we see below we have a
little diagram describing the different
steps so uh
representations are anonymized which is
a
an issue by itself why because uh the
the representative information is quite
informative for example uh uh you might
expect certain public organizations uh
that are known to to to be very
interested in environmental issues to
comment on on environmental related
policies uh so you can see there's some
uh
valuable information we are missing from
an advised presentations all this text
gets sliced into paragraphs and
Associated to policies against the
slicing as we as we saw uh in a talk
earlier today
um many Transformer based models are
limited in the number of tokens they can
they can deal with
and here we we basically work around the
issue because we actually need to slice
the large document and and usually
paragraphs are never too long
um but we do take care of that and and
finally you can normalize all these
documents local plan policies and
representations into a unifying schema
so basically we have a text ID of the of
the text inside the sequence
sequence of text which is basically a
representation or might be a section in
the local plan and so on or a policy and
this is then the data we we work with
and we consider the
different competing classification
models here I will not go into the
details but most of them as you can see
are bad based then we have a xlnet
specific specially based models as well
so so basically the most popular ones we
we took that them into account
and and then we compare them so how do
you compare them it's not like you have
a a data set where you have a
training and test and and you are kind
of done you you need to to see what is
the performance where you actually don't
have much data for training could be
like just 10 of the data set
which is already quite a lot if you
think that at the beginning you might
have zero samples for training or as you
as you advise you might get to 50 and 90
percent uh of the samples of the
paragraphs you can actually use for
training Additionally you cannot
I mean you you cannot leak information
by by considering one paragraph of one
representation in the training sample
and maybe the second paragraph of the
same representation for testing you you
need to to keep either completely for
testing or training each representation
so there's some uh little issues there
you you may be need to be careful and
then you also want to generalize across
different data sets and here we we had
access to to uh not perfect but but good
assets 3D assets the Derbyshire
Cambridge and Chester pencils
and how we compare them so you really
have a different configurations you can
use to simulate different stages in the
in the execution of the workflow so what
we did uh for for multiple
configurations we we measured accuracy
and then we looked at what is accuracy
for uh for um
for uh for the best model performing
model and then calculating the distance
to to the to the performance of the best
the best model so in this way what you
get uh you get distance statistics uh uh
to which whichever model you are
considering to the best one in each
configuration and from this Statistics
you can then look at uh uh what happens
if you sum up the errors or median
errors or Max arrows mean arrows and
then you can start comparing uh
all these different models as you can
see
we so let's have a look at the table
below we can see that in some errors uh
Bird plus distilbert they kind of are
similar
lower errors than the others if we go to
the median errors word and distributor
not too dissimilar so they perform
similarly in the median case if we look
at the kind of outliers where we really
get to the worst errors we see that
actually but for some reason uh was
quite unlucky at least in some cases and
and again for mean errors we we get
quite similar results but overall we saw
the digital bird performs pretty pretty
good across different uh
statistics for for the for
um for the distance sorry for the errors
and uh if we if we look here on the
right we see performance for the how
does it look like for one specific data
set when we use a 10 50 or 90 of the
data set for training so as you can see
uh it's uh for for most of the for most
of the configurations performance is not
super great but it's kind of similar so
uh the the the learning here that uh
it's actually more important to to
understand what is the what is a good
problem to work on and then performance
across different models it might be
different uh you you might then try to
to identify what is the best performing
model but that's kind of uh secondly uh
goal so it's way more important to make
sure that you actually work on the
correct problem
and let's go now back to to the case
where we have like a new consultation
and there's no training data so what do
we do so so uh here we we basically are
in the cold start problem uh which
concerns the issue that the system never
had access to any samples for training
uh no paragraphs yet with their
non-label so there's nothing to learn
from
here we see an example of of policy ID
which we can look up in the text if if
we are lucky
then each each policy is usually
associated with an ID but also with a
long name like the title of the policy
which is unlikely you will find it but
it's informative by itself there might
be some toponyms in it and some specific
keywords that you would find only for
for text relevant for this policy so
with this very simple heuristics you can
actually
classify between uh 10 24 percent of the
of the representations so from zero you
can consistently get at least 10 percent
representations with some kind of
prediction
now accuracy is not always 100 it
it varies quite a lot also by if we look
at different assets why do we have
errors here well
in many cases there are ambiguities here
we see an example below
where we see that certain representation
was mentioned in an issue that was uh uh
already captured or or covered by by
other policies as 15 and as 16 in this
case so what uh what the heuristic found
uh we basically got these two uh
policies as candidates but none of them
is actually the correct one uh policy
al6 was the correct one so so for in
this case it's uh if you don't really
understand the the the logic of the text
you are going through you might end up
in Android mistakes
and
let's uh let's now uh
proceed so what we saw so far we do have
a mod we do have a uh different models
we can we can consider we found the best
configuration uh we we have a strategy
to to start with some training samples
and and proceed in the in the iterative
process
can we improve performance somehow uh
um well what what we did we tried to
fine-tune the model
and actually in in our specific use case
we we had access to a lot of text with
no labels but the entire examination
library is actually uh
it actually contains millions of
paragraphs of text you can you can learn
from so you have plenty of unlabeled
text to to find to use for fine tuning
your models
and and secondly you can fine tune uh
training goals on on text not only from
the from the examination Library uh
relevant for the consultation you are
working on but also from other ones so
no one stops you to learn also from
other uh independent data sets
and we evaluated different strategies we
saw that uh
if we look at the overall performance
it's actually uh
uh good to just try to learn from as
much text as possible so if you have
access to to
three or or ten more
data sets it's actually good to use all
of them for fine tuning
if we just focus on on the best
performing predictions top 20
predictions we we saw the the opposite
it's actually uh more convenient to to
try to fine tune your model only from a
text which is uh within the examination
library that is relevant for the
representations you are you are working
with so depending a bit on on which
stage you are in in the entire workflow
of the of the verification process of
the representations you might choose a
one one strategy or the other
and uh
um now what what we saw so far we we
looked at performance in terms of
accuracy which is uh uh just one single
metric but but still it's quite
difficult to understand for uh for uh
for non-technical people people just
don't don't get what is the accuracy is
they care about how much time is this
word process taking my team uh so so we
have this problem uh to to try to
quantify uh what were what are the
benefits from categorization and what
are the benefits from the improved
searching through the the
representations
so what we did we created a simple
cost-based model where uh
each character in in a in our data set
was associated with a certain cost now
if the paragraph Was associated with the
uh if this the character came from a
paragraph associated with uh with the
correct label we we Associated a lower
cost compared to to the case where the
actually the label was was wrong why
because it takes more time to to correct
errors and in this way we try to to
model the the benefits of the of the
entire
workflow of course there are lots of
assumptions here so how much time are
you saving are you saving uh
0.001 or 0.0026 seconds per tractor
and this is a an ongoing discussion with
different authorities uh to understand
how much time it takes to to classify a
certain uh kind of uh
representations uh also not all
representations are equal so they might
vary quite a lot so this is why we try
to come up with some some bounds
for reasonable costs
then running simulations out of these
bounds to to to see how much variance
and and uh and how much benefits uh we
could we could obtain so how much time
we could save in our simulations for
both categorization and searching and we
actually saw that searching uh even
though the the machine learning
component is using uh is used to to
improve the categorization most of the
benefits are in searching so once uh you
you have a your data better indexed you
can use it much much better and that is
actually saving more time
categorization itself
um this is important why because uh uh
this also means that indexing and
searching through documents could be
extended to the entire examination
Library not limited to representations
so here we are just uh trying to to
improve a workflow which is really uh
the Tipping Point of the iceberg of how
much complexity uh it's there in
processing all these examination
libraries
um so uh why performance is so much
better for some data sets as you saw in
the in the graphs before performance can
can vary quite a lot so
we we looked a bit into into the
differences uh of all these data sets
and what we saw is that uh for example
policies IDs are more frequently present
in representations
so whatever whenever the policies I
policy IDs are present in the
representation text they get much easier
to to predict not surprisingly
this is uh kickstarting much faster also
the the training process so we just have
uh more training there to to start from
so instead of having maybe five ten
percent of the representations with uh
with some kind of uh prediction thanks
to keywords
we might have uh predictions for 50
percent of the representations
and this of course speeds up the the
process the different steps we we saw
before uh maybe you can still skip some
of the steps so basically you you can go
through it much faster uh and secondly
better matching of labels uh in the
local plan and the representation so you
you have to consider that all these
documents inside this library of
documents uh are not harmonized they
might have slightly different names for
the policies IDs might not match exactly
so this is a huge uh data cleaning issue
here so it's quite and also fixing the
the errors might introduce other kinds
of Errors so it's quite time consuming
uh and and it's it's quite a manual
process
and
also the number of uh different policies
it impacts the quality of your
classification process so if you have to
to come up with a prediction for for 20
different policies you have one problem
uh if you if you instead of policies
your categories are titles and subtitles
or in your local plan
you start having a dependencies between
the labels some labels might be more
generic than other labels and so on so
they might overlap slightly as well
it gets much more confused and you have
a potentially way more uh class labels
to predict for so it is different if you
want to predict for Crime labels or or
100 levels
and
so what uh if uh sorry if I will speed
up a bit
um yeah so consistency and data cleaning
not surprisingly still big issues and
one of our recommendations is actually
around uh standardization
and yeah so what are the benefits if we
try to summarize a bit what are the
benefits of our contributions
well faster categorization of the
representations with machine learning
how using pre-filled categorizations
secondly accelerated summaries of
representations text within
representations is now searchable at the
paragraph level much faster than than
before
and and additionally
now you have users using your platform
and you can do analytics on top of that
so you can start
estimating how much time is going to be
required to complete the task and so on
so better resource planning for the
local authorities as well here it's our
first prototype look like with voila so
very
text based I would say
but first to to this was our first
iteration and this is the the second
iteration of our prototype and actually
here I will also share that the the link
but you can actually try a demo of it
this is the wall architecture we we used
to experiment and deliver the demo so as
you can see uh it's quite a data
scientist can operate with a similar
stack in the web application demo plus
doing experimentation in collab locally
and we use the ml truck Library we
worked on to track experimentation track
experiments and analyze experiments and
wherever you see python we always have
this pins NLP python package we relied
on as a central code base so all the
coding notebooks everything slowly gets
merged into a package which is then used
for experimentation for for uh for the
web demo and so on so in this way
we start transitioning from a fast quick
quick prototype to something that we can
actually use
and yeah and very slow very quickly
actually so this is a
I wanted to have some code in this
presentation because there was no code
so so this is how we we have experiments
so so basically you create a session the
entire all the experimentation data is
stored in a relational database like
postgres or sqlite you have done
different steps you can combine the
pipeline load fit predict and evaluate
here and you have then different data
sets a different type of parameters and
you can then persist your your
experiments and potentially a
collaborator can can then work with you
loading the data set and adding more
configurations comparing performance and
so on what uh what I really like about
the solution is that
the data set itself as stored in uh in
particles for example is directly
clearable so uh whatever you you you
load in postgres likely you can just
create with any dashboarding solution
without relying on any python which is
nice because you can create dashboards
for your clients that don't need to to
rely on any kind of python Library they
wouldn't know how to use anyways
and I think here there are some ideas
for a
improving performance which I will uh
not cover but quickly yeah there are
more opportunities to to improve these
models but actually also to work on
other areas in the in the value chain of
the problem we worked on like
forecasting for resource planning and
text summarization
and that concludes my talk thanks a lot
[Applause]
thank you so much that was the closest
I've seen a very very real world kind of
problem for you know hard enough tasks
so we have uh some three questions here
on slido uh I'll start with them but I
have other questions what are the
tolerated error rates for the
categorization process how
um how in general people reached to
imperfect predictions
yeah so that's a very important point so
so it's very what is critical is that uh
in in any use case where machine
learning is involved is that your system
should degrade nicely if things don't
work actually so in our case if all the
predictions are wrong the system
performs uh as there wouldn't be any
machine learning model used so basically
we asked back to to the manual mode
where the the recommendations are wrong
and and the local Authority needs to to
identify the the correct labels manually
so this is what happens uh if if uh if
the the models don't perform at all so
it nicely degrades the performance it's
uh it's not like a not working kind of
um yeah so so that's uh how we handled
it it's not there's not really any
treasured I can share or or uh or value
I can share uh but uh my strongest
advice is to design for a smooth
degradation of performance
set fit efficient future Learning
Without promise
I I didn't
um but please come come later talk with
me happy very happy to learn more about
it thank you all right next one did you
use a python package or other service in
the PDF processing
if I'm not wrong PDF Miner is a python
package you can use for that yeah
that's what we used
all right next one who is maintaining
the model long term is there some
in-house ml talent in the government
to hand over and maintain the project
yeah so so
what's uh the the good and bad thing
about this this model is that once they
are used ones they are thrown away
you're kind of done with the work so you
don't really need to
maintain it in production for other kind
of uh so so it just needs to to be
working properly through the
verification process through the
execution of the workflow and right now
what what you saw is not in production
uh but many many councils are interested
to to have Pilots with us on this so
hopefully this summer we're gonna use it
and uh yeah I will be the lucky one
dealing with training and quality
I don't know what's not working but I
have another follow-up question I
couldn't
help space
you're trying to support the officials
can you maybe walk us through have you
thought about supporting the users the
community so for example you said you
have forms then in the forms could it be
would it be possible for them to
directly comment on each
yeah that's a that's a very good
question so uh what what we have been
asked to do from uh from the planning
inspectorate is actually also to to
provide recommendations how can we
improve what shall we do and uh and we
really uh
recommended to to have standard
standardization procedures in place and
design the consultation online
consultation platform in such a way that
you can comment directly very close to
the policy so that you don't need to
specify the policy this means that the
policy is associated programmatically
it's easier for the user and then it's
also easier from on our side because uh
there's no data quality issue it's not
there's no there's no issue there and
yeah I I would say
we we contributed some recommendations
in the direction of how can you better
design a consultation platform and yeah
I hope that was clear yeah that answers
my question any anyone else here or
Slidell
by the way I say is not working because
in my phone it appears the other
questions from the previous talk but
maybe it's just my problem
yeah I'm I'm I'm it was a previous
question but I'm curious about
processing the PDFs because in my
experience and maybe on Rome that's a
hard problem because the the format is
not fixed everyone uploads different
kind of text and how that app affects
the performance because was that how can
you gain by improving the PDF processing
or that subroing that you consider
itself already yeah no it's not uh not
solved
so server I will share
to to
examples so first example a greater
Cambridge local plan
nice online website for some
consultation and
which contains the local plan itself in
an HTML format and you can comment
directly on it each policy separate page
and so on so uh it's very easy to it's
basically a web scripting very easy web
scraping to do this is not even a PDF
this is a pdf version but no need to to
use it if there's a an easier to uh is a
method to to actually access the same
information a better structured way
second case
another another local plan just a PDF
this time
different policies only way they are
separated is by colors of some boxes in
some headings of the PDFs which of
course is rather manual so we basically
spent two weeks trying to come up with a
custom rules to identify good ways to to
process these PDFs so and it quality
varies a lot then regardless of how much
time invest in the pre-processing you
still see that there is a very large
variation in terms of performance
afterwards uh
so
I would say PDF could be a good format
uh
for some applications but but here in
our use case it's not really a great fit
through the entire processing of
representations
information gets processed structured in
spreadsheets
someone is created and then all the
spreadsheets all that structured
information is lost is stretched and
then only the final PDF shared so as you
can see there's a lot of space to to
harmonize and streamline the processing
and improving how information flows
without destroying it for example
I hope that helped
you already touched upon this but I'll
ask that can you share more about how
you handle the token limit
yeah so
slicing of of text
um so let's say that you have a
so one paragraph is usually not so long
so usually you don't need so much so
many tokens to cover one paragraph
uh
so what we did we we made sure we
decided on a threshold so what is the
maximum length of a paragraph
uh now
depending on the representation you
might you might need to be more or less
aggressive to get close to that
threshold in some cases if you are very
loose with your uh heuristics uh entire
very large documents might end up being
just one paragraph uh uh other cases you
just break it down too much like uh 10
words each paragraph and that's it
so I would say the the we use the a lot
of heuristics to come up with a
reasonable amount of text within each
paragraph which was not overflowing uh
the number of tokens
thank you so much and that's all we have
and please give him a round of applause
[Applause]